rien le le président de la République
est totalement démonétisé en ce qui
concerne son expression moi je note deux
choses la première c'est
l'inélégance du président de la
République vis-à-vis de son nouveau
Premier ministre à qui il coupe l'herbe
sous le pied c'est vraiment parfaitement
inélégant j'allais dire totalement
contradictoire avec la pratique
républicaine qui fait qu'on attend que
le premier ministre s'exprime bientôt
devant le Parlement dans un discours
politique général et le président de la
République vient lui saperer finalement
sa par parle
publique comme il avait fait avec
Édouard Philippe ça montre le peu de
crédit que donne d'ailleurs le président
de la République à son premier ministre
il considère que celui-ci n'a pas de
marge de manœuvre c'est lui qui dicte
les choses et puis mauvais coup au
Parlement aussi de s'exprimer avant que
le premier ministre Vienne présenter son
discours de politique générale oui
d'accord mais autre chose aussi un
mauvais coup porté au Parlement oui
c'est un mauvais coup c'est un mauvais
coup porté à la démocratie parlementaire
et puis autre chose c'est que le
Président de la République nous a déjà
habitué à ces formats par qu'on nous dit
c'est une conférence de pr XXL asse
superlatif qui à la fin ne débouche sur
rien moi je me souviens et je garde un
mauvais souvenir des débats des gilets
jaunes on disait c'est des heures de
débat il a parlé de tout et à la fin que
reste-t-il de tout cela rien donc non
nous n'attendons rien mais je crois que
les Français n'attendent pas grand-chose
du président de la
République